donc là je voulais l'empêcher partir
parce que j'ai compris il va reprendre
là il m'a foncé dessus avec la voiture
on adopte moi j'ai sauté sur
l'arrestation et m'a coincé là
maintenant pour nous sommes quelques
minutes après l'agression
daniel la victime est sous le choc et
parle aux policiers aujourd'hui s'il n'a
pas souhaité témoigner devant nos
caméras nous a expliqué qu'il avait pris
tout de suite conscience de la menace
que représentait son agresseur une
menace pour lui mais surtout pour les
autres
son altruisme contraste avec l'inaction
des clients de la station service jérôme
monier le patron de daniel et
propriétaire de la mercedes volée a vu
la vidéo surveillance
il est tout simplement sidéré la vidéo
dure onze minutes pendant 11 minutes il
dit aidez moi aidez moi pendant cinq
minutes il dit mettez une voiture devant
le mec il a pas couteau il l'a découpé
avec la clé de sa voiture donc il c'est
du cynisme ansa nous n'avons pas pu nous
procurer la vidéosurveillance mais nous
l'avons visionnée
on y voit un agresseur déterminée et non
armés frapper sa victime pendant près de
deux minutes avant de tenter de
l'écraser devant des témoins indifférent
le patron de daniel n'entend pas en
rester là
pour chaque personnes que j'identifie
sur la vidéo je vais porter plainte pour
non assistance à personne en danger
ça aurait pu arriver à mon fils puisque
c'est lui qui d'habitude va mettre de
l'essence dans ma voiture j'aurais pu
arriver à n'importe qui aujourd'hui
daniel la victime est sortie de
l'hôpital il a plusieurs hématomes et
points de suture son médecin l'a déclaré
en incapacité de travailler pendant huit
jours